reina efectivamente tuvo acercamientos
con América Latina le pregunto Cuál es
el papel la imagen que tenemos aquí en
América Latina respecto a las monarquías
algo que históricamente es muy lejano
para nosotros
pues es una relación muy complicada
Sabes porque principalmente nosotros
hacer países que fueron colonizados
tenemos la perspectiva de las monarquías
como algo malo como algo negativo como
algo que no hace parte de nosotros Y de
lo que debemos liberarnos sin embargo
algo que sí disfrutamos muchísimo aquí
en Latinoamérica es saber de la vida de
la monarquía saber qué hacen saber cómo
realizan sus actividades su cotidianidad
además que se tenía un muy gran aprecio
aquí en Latinoamérica a Lady Diana por
su imagen favorable hacia la corona
Entonces no solamente benefició a la
corona británica la imagen de Lady Diana
sino que aquí en Latinoamérica muchas
personas amaban su figura por ser tan
cercana a las personas por acercarse a
diferentes momentos históricos como lo
fue la lucha contra el sida entonces la
visión que se tiene acá en Latinoamérica
primero es como si la reina de
Inglaterra es muy importante Por una
parte Por otra parte tiene como lo que
ocurrió con Lady Diana y por otra parte
se tiene como esos rezagos colonialistas
que se tienen como de estas personas en
realidad están ahí porque razón como se
encuentran es una dicotomía esta
relación entre latinoamérica los
latinoamericanos y en este caso las
monarquías precisamente mientras
hablamos llega a la reacción del
presidente de Brasil Yair bolsonaro
quien ha decretado Valentina tres días
de luto en Brasil por la muerte de la
reina Isabel II nos contaba acerca de
que precisamente a nivel histórico es
algo muy alejado para nosotros hablar de
la Reina Isabel segunda hablar de esa
cercanía pero creo Usted que a pesar de
esa distanciamiento pese aquí es algo
lejano en algunos países sigue teniendo
digamos a nivel de popularidad cierto
aprecio este tipo tener una monarquía
Claro que sí en algunas instancias se
puede tener en cuenta como en el caso de
los británicos la importancia de la
Reina Isabel una figura unificadora No
Solamente era la red en sí misma sino
que ella mostraba la lealtad la
importancia de tener el reino de la
unidad incluso la mancomunidad de
Naciones lo representa por eso mismo
veíamos hace un poco al presidente al
Primer Ministro Justin trudea esto es
una cosa muy muy importante y en la
cuestión aquí de latinoamérica a pesar
de la lejanía que puede representar la
Reina Isabel era un icono del arte pop
de la popularidad muchos de nosotros
solo hemos vivido solo con la Reina
Isabel y sabemos Quién es la reina de
Inglaterra por su importancia política a
pesar de que no tome decisiones
directamente la gente sabe quién es la
Reina Isabel incidió de una u otra forma
en su vida saber el estilo de vida de la
realeza principalmente la británica
porque pues tenemos acá relación con la
principalmente con los españoles pero no
creo que exista esa ese tipo de arraigo
Memorial tan cercano como se tiene con
la Reina Isabel por su misma forma de
ser tan real en el sentido desarrollo en
el sentido británico de la zona
aprovecho que tengo que tengo esta
comunicación con ustedes como
historiadora que se marca hoy a nivel
histórico con la muerte de una reina
como no como no la vida en otro momento
de la historia que supone esto para las
monarquías Cómo se cree usted que va a
ser el futuro después de la muerte de la
reina Isabel II en lo que se refiere
para estas para la realeza
es un futuro muy complicado es un futuro
muy incierto porque la Reina Isabel
mostraba la unidad pero era una unidad
femenina que mostraba fuerza y
determinación cosa que no se puede
reflejar de una manera similar a Carlos
porque Carlos siempre fue el hijo que
estuvo ahí esperando el trono esperando
el trono pero estuvo en medio de
diversos escándalos toda la cuestión con
Lady Diana su relación con Camila Parker
Bones Y que ahora él sea el rey
probablemente podría mostrar una
desunión en el país es algo muy complejo
porque la reina siempre intentó como ser
alguien muy cercana a su pueblo
infectando diferentes obras comunitarias
diferentes actos protocolarios y Carlos
se representa como una persona mucho más
lejana debido a lo que vivió con Diana
entonces puede esto Mostrar la fractura
de la monarquía británica